[Musique]
dès l'entrée près de 2000 enfants
découvrent un univers qui leur est dédié
en famille ou avec une assistante
familiale
quelle que soit leur parcours de vie
cette journée nationale et pour eux même
si le démarrage n'est pas toujours à la
hauteur ses enfants savent pourquoi ils
sont venus d'albi
[Applaudissements]
et tous les emplois rôle et walder vous
nous tapez en tant que norme a été bien
parce que moi je connais ce droit et si
on profitait à peu aussi également
présents ce jour là les enfants confiés
à l'aide sociale à l'enfance des jeunes
accompagnés au quotidien par les
assistantes familiales qui utilisent
tous les moyens pour les faire grandir
ya beaucoup de davantage de pratiquer la
portion à 16,1 au nouveau psychomoteur
au niveau de bienveillance c'est aussi
avec un cadre un ghana discipline
et puis bah ça permet aussi de
progresser un certain marmailles sont
partis en métropole ont ramené des
titres tout simplement
et puis il ya beaucoup d'esprit de
partage
à
[Musique]
nous mais qui a du sens car dans la vie
la chance n'est pas la même pour tous
3500 enfants sont sous la protection
légale du département ça n'a pas d'écho
si on fait une journée de l'enfance sans
l'enfant et ce sans leur offrir cette
journée c'est l'épaule elle doit être
elle doit être significative elle doit
être parlant et elle doit être suivie
finalement d'actes concrets et là que
concret c'est ce qu'on a organisées pour
eux aujourd'hui dans ce domaine premier
social mais surtout de l'enfance et de
la petite enfance est une action
obligatoire certes mais aussi
volontariste du département et de la
précédente de 2 d'être amis derrière ces
structures est derrière ces enfants de
la paix a mis en passant par les
collèges du nss le conseil départemental
des jeunes ou encore les subventions de
voyage pédagogique le développement de
l'enfant est au centre des
préoccupations de la collectivité
[Musique]